et avec nous aujourd'hui le général
Dominique Trincant bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous on cherche de
la mission militaire française auprès de
l'ONU et Patrick Martin jaunier bonjour
Patrick merci d'être là enseignant en
sciences po spécialiste des questions
européennes et internationales auteur du
livre qu'on va voir l'Europe a-t-elle un
avenir grande question c'est aux
éditions nous a rejoint on va parler
avec vous de la contre-offensive
ukrainienne où on est-elle elle semble
marquer le PAM et est-ce une pause pour
permettre à l'Ukraine de revoir sa
stratégie où est-ce un leurre vous nous
direz ce que vous en pensez dans ce
contexte on analysera les déclarations
d'Emmanuel Macron hier soir le chef de
l'État qui a défendu sa stratégie de
défense entière de l'Europe la guerre en
Ukraine a mis en lumière ses faiblesses
vous analyserez tout ça dans quelques
instants d'abord on va parler de
l'actualité dans nos régions
et l'actualité dans nos régions elle est
aussi militaire la loi de programmation
militaire arrive en séance au Sénat la
semaine prochaine un budget à la hausse
413 milliards d'euros sur 7 ans consacré
à l'armement et du côté de Saint-Étienne
l'entreprise Verney-Carron espère bien
en bénéficié c'est une usine d'armement
regarde ce reportage de Coraline Beurier
pour nos partenaires de TL7
cette loi l'entreprise d'armement
stéphanoise Vernet Caron attend de pied
ferme et si cette subvention pourrait
être un véritable appui dans
l'accélération de la production des
armes signées vernées Caron les
dirigeants du groupe restent eux encore
sceptiques quant au montant apercevoir
piment la loi de programmation militaire
comme vous l'avez dit elle est
importante elle est imposante maintenant
il faut regarder un certain nombre
d'éléments essayer de décrypter un petit
peu ce qu'il y a derrière ce mammouth
qui est présenté d'abord c'est une loi
de programmation pluriannuelle donc il
faut que année après année le Parlement
et les gouvernements successifs ou les
ministres successifs et continue de
soutenir cette loi dans cette direction
mais voilà il faut bien déjà encore une
fois remettre en contexte le fait que
c'est une loi pleurer annuelle moi
j'attends de voir si année après année
sera voté j'espère qu'effectivement vers
les Caron sera soutenu par l'État dans
ce programme de réindustrialisation et
dans ce projet de réindustrialisation de
la partie de petits calibres en France
ces dernières années l'entreprise s'est
dressée comme un incontournable de
l'armement avec une cadence de
production vue à la hausse un essor du
haut besoin croissant de l'armée
française face au conflit en Ukraine
vers necarons croisent donc les doigts
et espèrent bénéficier de cette
subvention de l'État qui existe à
remettre l'accent sur la défense
militaire du pays un terrain de jeu où
la firme stéphanois s'est déjà imposée
comme une des plus grandes usines
d'armements françaises alors on voit
cette usine d'armement en général
trinquant qui espère évidemment
bénéficier de la LPM est-ce que les
sommes débloquées pour cette loi de
programmation militaire le gouvernement
parle d'un budget historique 413
milliards d'euros sur cet an sont à la
hauteur pour remettre notre armée à
niveau oui alors 413 milliards pour la
loi de programmation ça veut dire que
deux lois de programmation successives
double le budget de la défense donc
c'est quand même assez considérable
l'intervenant de verney carron a raison
il faut que tous les ans ceci soit
respectés dans la loi de programmation
qui arrive à sa fin ça a été le cas donc
faut espérer que la fois le cas il y a
beaucoup c'est aussi une des critiques
de cette loi de programmation militaire
il y a beaucoup d'engagements qui valent
pour après le quinquennat oui alors je
rappelle que c'était la même chose alors
la grosse différence c'est que le
quinquennat c'est poursuivi par un autre
quinquennat ce qui ne sera pas le cas du
suivant donc alors les j'ai vu que les
sénateurs en commission voudraient
accélérer les financements initiaux
c'est à dire avoir plus de financement
au début et donc un petit peu moins
après moi ma question ce sont les
finances publiques est-ce que les
finances publiques sont capables
d'absorber ça parce que doublement du
budget de la défense c'est un bel
investissement il faut rappeler que
pendant 20 ans il y a eu dividendes de
la paix comme excuse on a fait
dégringolé les budgets de la défense
donc il y a eu un premier complètement
si vous voulez si tu veux
regarder vers un peu vers l'avant on a
voulu économiser tout de suite ce qui
veut dire que la première loi de
programmation c'est ce qu'on a appelé
une loi de réparation
pour essayer de moderniser un peu
maintenant c'est une loi de
modernisation avec la prise en compte de
ce qui se passe en Ukraine en rappelant
simplement que l'Ukraine la France n'est
pas l'Ukraine et que donc les problèmes
qui se posent en Ukraine ne sont pas
forcément les mêmes qui se posent en
France je rappelle que nous sommes une
puissance deté et donc l'harmonie
nucléaire représente une part importante
de budget il faut pas l'oublier alors
que les autres pays n'ont pas ça et ça
c'est quand même le cœur de notre
défense la France est sûr si j'ose dire
d'abord parce qu'elle a la défense la
dissuasion nucléaire donc je pense que
tout ceci est un très bel effort le
diable est dans les détails
effectivement il faudra regarder chaque
année il faudra voir si on peut un peu
accélérer au début ou pas mais je pense
que elle montre un engagement très fort
de la France oui Patrick Martin Jeannet
oui tout à fait je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec le journal trinquant c'est
un engagement politique majeur et je
dirais que cela doit dépasser les
divisions politiques et l'éventuelles
succession après et d'Emmanuel Macron
pas uniquement un engagement purement
politique c'est un engagement de la
nation et je crois que c'est très
important parce que comme le dit le
ministre des Armées effectivement on
croyait que la paix était définitivement
installée en réalité c'est la guerre
l'Ukraine c'est la guerre en plein cœur
de l'Europe donc on s'aperçoit qu'il
faut rester crédible la dissuasion du
nucléaire certes les nouvelles
technologies parce qu'on a vu que la
guerre aussi c'était des nouvelles
technologies dans le tableau que vous
avez mis je n'ai pas vu par exemple ce
qui était l'espace on investit
considérablement il y aura 6 milliards
d'investissements dans l'espace ce c'est
ce que le nouveau le ministre a dit ce
sont les espaces de conflictualité des
nouveaux espaces de conflictualité et
donc c'est moderniser les drones les
défis technologiques l'espace tout ça
fait également partie des priorités de
la France qui dépassent les clivages
partisans donc ça me paraît tout à fait
important de montrer que la France est
là en essayant également de défendre
l'industrie française vous avez montré
Saint-Étienne mais également on voit ce
qui se passe avec l'Allemagne une
industrie européenne qui vont permettre
effectivement de mutualiser tout ce qui
est défense européenne on en parle dans
quelques secondes de l'Allemagne quelle
doit être les priorités pour vous
général trinquant de cette loi de
programmation militaire mais je le
disais les priorités c'est la
modernisation et la prise en compte ce
qui vient d'être évoqué la prise en
compte de nouvelles conflictualités le
cyber l'espace les drones toutes choses
sur lequel on était alors en particulier
sur les drones on était un peu en retard
sur le cyber on était bien rentré dedans
et donc là il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
choses à voir une petite un petit aparté
sur le recrutement parce que toutes les
armées
occidentales globalement ont un problème
de recrutement la France jusqu'à
maintenant n'en a pas eu mais avec la
compétitivité je parle du cyber par
exemple les industries privées recrutent
énormément dans des conditions
évidemment très différentes des armées
et donc là il y a un effort à faire
alors il y a recrutement gardé aussi les
personnes qui ont mis dans l'armée parce
que c'est une question il y en a
beaucoup qui rentrent et qui repart
exactement alors il y a un phénomène
aussi intéressant dont on parle pas
beaucoup c'est le doublement des
réservistes et là vous avez un point
d'entrée quand vous doublez les
réservistes ça peut être des gens qui
quittent le service mais qui reste
réserviste donc c'est quelque sorte une
passerelle entre le privé et les armées
et qu'il était extrêmement intéressant
de d'arriver à à fructifier j'allais
dire mais c'est vraiment les efforts
sont à faire là dessus juste une petite
remarque aussi
la loi de programmation en clair c'est
nous sommes le nucléaire j'en ai parlé
l'outre-mer permettait à quelqu'un qui
était présent à New York auprès des
Nations Unies la France est une nation
globale elle est en Amérique du Sud elle
est dans l'océan Indien elle est dans le
Pacifique et ça par exemple l'Ukraine ne
l'est pas donc tous ces phénomènes sont
à prendre en compte également on va
parler de l'Europe puisqu'il est
Emmanuel Macron a lancé un message en
marge du Salon du Bourget il y a une
vingtaine de ministres de la Défense et
des armées qui étaient réunis à Paris
Emmanuel Macron a défendu sa stratégie
de défense anti-aérienne de l'Europe la
guerre en Ukraine a mis en lumière les
carences de celle-ci il a annoncé que la
France l'Estonie la Hongrie la Belgique
est Chypre allait acheter des missiles
solaires de très courte portée mistrale
et il a également lancé un message le
chef de l'État qu'on pourrait résumer
par l'Europe doit protéger l'Europe
on peut décider d'utiliser l'argent de
nos contribuables à monter des budgets
de la défense pour mieux acheter ce que
les Américains continueront de produire
moi je crois qu'on peut être plus fort
en tant qu'amer réussir à développer une
base industrielle de défense et de
technologie qui crée de l'emploi chez
nous et bien utiliser l'argent du
contribuable et ce faisant gagner en
souveraineté parce qu'on sera moins
dépendant des choix technologiques
simplement faut standardiser davantage
c'est un message à l'Allemagne Patrick
Martin Janet oui très clairement un
message à Olaf schols qui lui a un
projet qui regroupe 14 pays de l'Union
européenne cette défense aérienne et
donc je crois que à une fois le
chancelier et le président français ont
raison l'argent des contribuables la
mutualisation européenne ce sera le
premier pas de la défense européenne
simplement il y a un malentendu entre la
France et l'Allemagne car lorsque vous
savez c'est facile de parler de la
défense européenne la mutualisation et
c'est aussi légitime chacun veut faire
prévaloir ses champions nationaux nous
en avons l'Allemagne en a également donc
aujourd'hui il y a une sorte de
malentendu et qui dure depuis déjà de 3
ans avec la suppression des conseils des
ministres franco-allemand et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui la coopération européenne
est très très importante il y a un
pilier européen de la défense au sein de
l'OTAN où il faut aller sur le sur la
pas le pas d'une défense européenne
malheureusement ça passera d'abord par
une mutualisation des armements et
effectivement lorsque le président de la
République dit il faut utiliser
correctement l'argent du contribuable en
réalité oh la chose va vous dire
exactement la même chose il faut
mutualiser parce que il ne pense pas de
la même manière et c'est un message vif
à l'Allemagne qui a envoyé hier Emmanuel
Macron l'Allemagne elle joue pas assez
européen
alors j'ai bien écouté hier
l'intervention du président c'était très
clair lorsque il a dit par exemple
puisque vous savez que le projet
allemand c'est essentiellement acheté
américain et israélien sur la base du
dôme d'acier qui existe en Israël le
président a rappelé que Israël était 200
fois plus petit que l'Europe et que donc
une défense européenne ne pouvait pas se
calquer sur une défense israélienne et
donc il fallait réfléchir
stratégiquement à notre besoin au lieu
d'acheter sur le court terme ce qui est
un peu la réaction des Allemands faut
rappeler que les Allemands l'armée
allemande qui a un budget important sans
nucléaire elle a un budget qui est plus
important que la France mais elle s'est
aperçue globalement et son chef
d'état-major lui-même l'a dit au début
de la guerre en Ukraine il a dit je peux
rien déployer donc c'est une catastrophe
absolue pour l'Allemagne donc d'un seul
coup on dit on met 100 milliards sur la
table et on va ranger tout ça et au bout
de 6 mois on s'aperçoit que les 100
milliards ne produisent pas grand chose
donc il faut éviter le court terme
les Allemands actuellement en achetant
américain je reprendrai la parole de
Madame parler que j'aime beaucoup
article 5 ne veut pas dire F-35 donc ça
veut dire que c'est pas parce qu'on va
faire collectif qu'on doit acheter
américain pour faire collectif il faut
qu'on évalue nos besoins et qu'en
fonction des besoins on s'organise pour
construire collectivement et c'était là
le message du Président hier ça veut
dire que l'Europe de la défense est
encore loin ah oui bien sûr c'est à dire
que à force de parler de l'Europe de la
défense on y croit si vous voulez le
problème aujourd'hui c'est qu'on en est
pas encore là mais le président de la
République a tout à fait raison de dire
il faut aller sur le chemin d'une
défense européenne mais les parcours les
obstacles seront très très nombreux
s'agissant du dôme israélien c'est
peut-être un petit pays mais c'est
quelque chose qui a été très efficace
notamment dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme et je crois qu'en associant
Israël à d'autres pays ça peut être
extrêmement efficace aussi donc il faut
s'entendre il faut accepter de
mutualiser et c'est ça la principale le
principal conflit entre la France et
l'Allemagne nous n'arrivons pas à
discuter on le voit pour la viande
combat européen le Scaff ça ça crée
énormément de difficultés donc je crois
qu'il faut se mettre autour d'une table
et notamment il y a un instrument qui
peut être utilisé c'est le Fond Européen
de défense qui constitue le début d'une
mutualisation du matériel il est doté de
croire je crois d'environ 7 à 8
milliards jusqu'en 207 ce n'est pas
suffisant et c'est ça aujourd'hui qu'il
faut creuser un mot peut-être sur
l'annonce hier soir d'Emmanuel Macron
qui a donc annoncé que la France avec
quatre autres pays la Hongrie la
Belgique Chypre et l'Estonie allait
acheter des missiles seul air de très
coût de portée Mistral qu'est-ce qu'il
faut voir dans cette annonce une alors
donc mutualisation effectivement bon le
deuxième point naturellement c'est que
c'est du matériel français donc on est
content d'avoir un contrat français et
puis que sais-tu une gamme simplement du
missile à courte portée la deuxième
annonce qu'il a fait c'est le
déploiement du système Mamba Italo
français en Ukraine donc ça montre que
c'est opérationnel donc effectivement on
est dans la mutualisation mais on est on
en est au début et pour avoir une
couverture de défense aérienne alors
petite remarque sur l'anti-aérien et la
défense aérienne le président a utilisé
le terme défense anti-aérienne
évidemment les aviateurs se sont tout de
suite un jour chirurgés en disant c'est
la défense aérienne donc voilà
on va parler de la contre-offensive
ukrainienne avant de vous entendre
mission à faire un point sur cette
contre-intensive avec vous Mathias voilà
ça faisait plusieurs mois qu'on nous
expliquait qu'il ne fallait pas partir
trop tôt qu'il fallait garder un effet
de surprise et bien deux semaines après
le début officiel de la contre-offensive
les gains sont bien maigres Oriane pour
leur selon les services de renseignement
estonien l'armée ukrainienne n'aurait
reconquille qu'une centaine de
kilomètres carrés principalement dans
l'ouest du Dombas alors très
concrètement il y a grosso modo à
plusieurs fronts de contre-offensif des
petits fronts dans le sud de loblastes
de l'ougance que par exemple autour de
la ville de criminat à l'est de quartier
ou encore à l'ouest de l'aublastes de
zaporigia près de la ville de dollinka
et ses conquêtes et bien elles se font
km par kilomètre pratiquement par
centaines de mètres dans certaines
régions comme à l'Ouest de Donetsk près
de marinka ou encore en bordure de
darkmouth où les combats on le sait sont
d'une très haute intensité alors c'est
manœuvre elles sont rendues difficiles
par différents facteurs la Russie a eu
le temps de fortifier ses positions il
est également délicat de faire avancer
des colonnes de tank sans pouvoir les
encadrer et les protéger par des
batteries anti-aériennes qui pour le
moment continuent de protéger les
grandes villes car une contre-offensive
lente elle est elle est elle contient
une protéger les grandes villes donc on
trouve aussi volante mais une stratégie
assumée par l'Ukraine
poser nos troupes avance position par
position pas à pas nous avançons cette
semaine nous avons eu Rammstein et
l'essentiel est la rapidité de
l'approvisionnement la semaine prochaine
nous aurons de nouvelles communications
importantes avec nos partenaires pour le
bien de nos mouvements pour le bien des
armes pour le bien de nos guerriers qui
ont tout ce dont ils ont besoin
alors déjà le reconnaît officiellement
qu'il y a une contre-offensive ce n'est
pas rien Vladimir Poutine lui-même s'est
exprimé à ce sujet lors du Forum
économique international de
Saint-Pétersbourg c'était il y a
quelques jours pour vous vous en doutez
minimiser la portée de la manœuvre
dans certaines zones les unités
ukrainiennes ont atteint la première
ligne de défense russe elles ont échoué
ce n'est pas la question ils ont atteint
leur objectif dans aucune des zones
c'est ce qui compte le président russe a
d'ailleurs au cours de cette même prise
de parole dit que plusieurs chats
occidentaux les Léopards Allemands
avaient été détruits ou brûlé c'est les
termes employés qui lancerait de même
pour des FCF des F-16 si jamais les
alliés de l'Ukraine venaient à lui en
fournir un point on va parler de
l'Europe dans quelques instants mais un
point avec vous peut-être général
trinquant sur la contre-offensive on en
est où aujourd'hui de cette
contrefaction moi j'apprécie beaucoup
quand le président Poutine dit l'Ukraine
n'a pas atteint ses objectifs cognait-il
les objectifs de l'Ukraine certainement
pas donc c'est un commentaire qui permet
de dire que tout se déroule comme
d'habitude et que les alors il faut
d'abord premier point la Russie a eu un
an pour installer ses défenses à une
exception près je vous demande d'être
attentif dans les semaines qui viennent
ces backmouth backmouth la défense n'a
pas été organisée tout simplement parce
que la Russie continue à avancer et donc
c'est la zone dans laquelle il n'y a pas
de fortification et c'est le troisième
axe de progression des
Ukrainiens deuxième point
le temps médiatique n'est pas le temps
de la guerre et donc au bout du huit
jours en s'impatiente parce que ça n'a
pas percé je rappelle qu'en Normandie en
juin 4 il a fallu six semaines aux
Américains à toute l'armée américaine et
britannique pour arriver à percer donc
soyons un peu patient le troisième
non ça veut dire ça veut dire que dans
un premier temps vous avez trois
brigades sur trois axes je rappelle
qu'il y a 9 brigades derrière donc 10 à
20% engagé qui sont là pour tester le
dispositif voire où ça peut progresser
alors aujourd'hui moi je suis totalement
incapable de vous dire ce que les
Ukrainiens vont déduire de cette
première phase ils vont évaluer où ils
en sont où ils peuvent percer ou pas et
là où ils peuvent envoyer leurs réserves
et le point important c'est non
seulement bien sûr le bouclier russe mis
en place mais surtout les réserves
russes je rappelle que lorsque il y a eu
le le barrage a explosé ça avait pour
but de dégager toute une zone qui était
inondée et de prendre des la force russe
de cette zone pour les mettre ailleurs
en réserve donc l'intérêt pour les
Ukrainiens aujourd'hui c'est voir où
l'avancée progresse elle progresse plus
à bakmouth qu'ailleurs au passage et
deuxième point où sont les réserves
parce que évidemment en fonction de là
où sont les réserves on va voir là où
attaquer mais c'est une première phase
qui s'est déroulée le chef d'État parce
que là on a l'impression alors vous le
dites un médiatiquement qu'on est un peu
dans une pause est-ce que pour vous ça
marque la fin d'une première phase
est-ce que c'est une pause stratégique
parce que l'Ukraine est en train de
réadapter sa stratégie ou est-ce que
c'est un leur vis-à-vis des ruches non
je pense que c'est une pause pour nous
parce qu'on a toujours 48 heures de
retard par rapport ce qui se passe sur
le terrain premier point le chef
d'état-major estonien disait il est bien
renseigné que il y a probablement
pendant une semaine il n'y aura pas plus
d'avancées parce qu'il va falloir placer
les réserves là où il faut donc
attendons j'allais dire une quinzaine de
jours pour pouvoir commenter sur
l'avancée de l'offensive
j'aime bien c'est brouillard de la
guerre ouais parce que on vous dit on
est toujours un peu en retard c'est pas
exactement ce qui se passe mais certains
collègues du général trinquant d'autres
généraux me disent en réalité la
contre-offensive n'a jamais vraiment
commencé il y a une première phase
peut-être il y aura une autre phase
est-ce que il y a pas une stratégie
derrière premièrement deuxièmement alors
anamalière qu'elle a ministre de la
adjoint de la défense ukrainienne a dit
hier soir que la situation était quand
même extrêmement difficile donc
effectivement c'est un fait que il y a
un progrès il gagne mais certains disent
que c'est pour gagner effectivement
quelques quelques kilomètres carrés
entre 250 ou 500 mètres en avant voire 2
km donc la progression elle est là mais
je crois qu'effectivement c'est ce que
disait le Général trécore il y a un
aspect politique et psychologie très
important plus vous gagnez du terrain
plus ça donne du moral au troupes et
plus ça montre que les Ukrainiens sont
capables effectivement d'avoir une
contre-offensive donc ça c'est très
important de le montrer évidemment
on ne parle pas de df16 toujours les
mêmes avions de chasse qui pourraient
donner une suprématie ils ne sont pas
encore livrés la question est
aujourd'hui de dire quand est-ce que
est-ce qu'il y aura une véritable
contre-offensive un blitzkrie qui leur
permettra de dégager beaucoup de
territoires ce n'est pas le cas encore
aujourd'hui donc il faut espérer que ça
continue on va en parler de cette
question d'avion on peut dire qu'elle a
commencé la contre-offensive ou pas et
il a commencé il y a plusieurs semaines
l'accord une offensive ça se demande
comment il y a déjà l'offensive
stratégique les frappes dans la
profondeur les attentats fait par les
partisans qui sont derrière les lignes
les frappes sur l'électronique sur les
PC etc et ça ça a commencé il y a déjà
un petit moment deuxième phase la phase
dont on dit qu'elle est en pause
aujourd'hui c'est à dire la
reconnaissance offensive on cherche sur
le terrain à concrétiser l'information
qu'on a par ailleurs parce que c'est
bien de voir les lignes de défense mais
quelle est l'unité qui défend mieux sa
ligne que l'autre et ben il faut aller
tester il faut aller au contact et puis
la troisième phase c'est bien on a
trouvé la brèche on va créer la brèche
et on passe dans la casser la défense et
surtout l'exploitation parce que je
rappelle qu'une offensive vous avez deux
objectifs un objectif politique un
objectif militaire l'objectif militaire
c'est quoi c'est cassé la Défense russe
et arriver à chambouler le dispositif
russe l'offensive politique c'est quoi
c'est gagner du terrain parce que tous
les jours on annonce que des villages
sont libérés donc on est content sauf
que les premiers villages qui avaient
été libérés n'étaient pas tenus par les
Russes donc vous voyez psychologiquement
c'est bien on monte des drapeaux mais ça
représente pas grand chose et surtout ça
c'est la méthode pardonnez-moi du terme
type soviétique faut pas oublier que les
Russes sont des héritiers des
Soviétiques mais les Ukrainiens aussi et
donc psychologiquement gagner du terrain
c'est important pour la psychologie pour
les médias pour les politiques villages
par village c'est quand même important
mais que pour que ce soit décisif il va
falloir percer le fond mais que
militairement ça n'est pas important
mais politiquement c'est important un
autre élément qui était souligné les
Russes se disent suffisamment c'est que
depuis le temps qu'on parle de la
contre-offensive ukrainienne comme ils
ont eu le temps de s'y préparer donc on
a vu effectivement des tranchées et bien
mieux équipés malgré les
dysfonctionnements de l'armée russe
effectivement eux il y a ils n'ont pas
de problème en termes d'effectif de
recrutement ils envoient ils n'ont aucun
souci de la vie des hommes qui sont sur
place et donc ils ont eu le temps de se
préparer à cette contre-offensive et
quand on voit la mine réjouit de
Vladimir Poutine au forums économiques
de Saint-Pétersbourg qu'on se dit
effectivement que c'est le cas et que
certains estiment que cette
contre-offensive marque le pas donc
aujourd'hui effectivement vous savez on
dit il ne faut pas parler de la
stratégie militaire mais ça fait
plusieurs semaines que les Ukrainiens
parlent de contre-offensive donc c'est
vrai que d'une certaine façon les
troupes russes ont eu le temps de s'y
préparer est-ce que ça veut dire que le
gros déforce le gros de l'offensive est
à venir du côté ukrainien
je répète il y a à peu près 9 brigades
qui sont en réserve donc c'est là où si
vous voulez il faut bien ça n'est pas un
échec alors ça peut être un échec si il
y a aucune option qui se présente à
l'Ukraine et que dans ce cas là elle dit
bah je vais pas engager mes 9 brigades
parce que comme la vient d'être dit le
problème c'est quand même la sécurité
des personnels je rappelle que lorsque
les Russes montent des véhicules blindés
détruits le rôle du blindé c'est d'abord
de protéger le personnel donc moi qu'un
léopard et de chenilles cassé et soirées
si l'équipage a réussi à s'en tirer il a
rempli son rôle d'une certaine façon il
n'a pas rempli son rôle dans la casser
mais il a permis de protéger les
personnels donc c'est vrai que sur le
plan des personnels les Russes et les
Ukrainiens ne sont pas dans la même
position on l'a bien vu à backmouth et
Monsieur Prigogine d'ailleurs vient
d'annoncer que 35000 tenez-vous bien
35000 prisonniers russes peuvent rentrer
chez eux alors en Russie dans les
villages dit pas l'horreur c'est à dire
35000 prisonniers qui sont parfois des
criminels qui vont revenir parce les
gens ont appelé un rôle on parle pas des
35 000 qui ont été tués sur le terrain
et ça les Russes s'en foutent alors que
les Ukrainiens 35 000 hommes c'est
colossal pour eux et donc il y a ce
cette balance aussi se soucie de
protéger la vie des hommes qui n'est pas
le même d'un côté à l'autre du front
on va parler peut-être de l'Europe avant
de vous entendre un Matthias hein parce
que évidemment l'Europe a un rôle à
jouer les joues un rôle dans tout ça
absolument dans une interview publiée ce
dimanche dans le Parisien le commissaire
européen au Marché intérieur Thierry
Breton est revenu justement sur cette
contre-offensive pour le moment peu
fructueuse on l'a dit alors lorsqu'on
lui demande si de futurs aides
européennes seraient conditionnés à la
réussite de cette contre-offensive voilà
ce qu'il en dit
notre soutien n'est pas conditionnel ce
qui est impératif c'est que l'Ukraine
recouvre sa liberté et son territoire
nous sommes déterminés à lui fournir
tout le soutien dont elle a besoin nous
le faisons et nous le ferons nous allons
accroître les forts en matière de
livraison d'armes et de munitions car il
s'agit d'une guerre de haute intensité
une Europe qui se dit organisée pour
soutenir les Ukrainiens comme si cette
guerre allait encore durer plusieurs
mois voire davantage donc ça c'est tiré
breton qui dit ça aussi c'est un
véritable sujet il va falloir être en
capacité de soutenir les Ukrainiens
longtemps oui alors je pense qu'il y a
deux sujets là-dedans essentiel la
capacité de soutenir les munitions etc
etc donc l'organisation de l'Europe donc
il faut reconnaître qu'elle s'est
réveillée extrêmement vite qu'elle a pu
très rapidement la facilité européenne
de paix on discutait depuis des mois de
la fourniture d'armement létale par la
facilité européenne de paix en 48 heures
ça a été réglé donc l'Europe c'est bien
organisé mais le deuxième sujet c'est la
résilience des nations c'est à dire les
citoyens européens qui
euh accepte un certain nombre d'efforts
qu'il doit faire pour la défense de
l'Ukraine et qui se rendent bien compte
que la défense de l'Ukraine c'est un
sujet qui les concerne parce qu'il
s'agit pas seulement du franchissement
d'une frontière internationalement
reconnue par la Russie mais ça veut dire
qu'un membre permanent du Conseil de
sécurité a déchiré les accords qu'il
avait signé or ça dans l'organisation de
murdes depuis
1945 c'est totalement inadmissible donc
c'est un vrai sujet de fond ça n'est pas
uniquement un problème de frontière
oui Europe 1 l'Europe est extrêmement
présente tout à fait d'accord à la réagi
avec célérité et surtout pour les achats
groupés d'armement et également
vis-à-vis de la candidature de l'Ukraine
à l'Union européenne première étape d
quelques semaines après la guerre de
candidature officielle de l'Ukraine à
l'Union européenne en terme d'armement
c'est très important et Thierry Breton a
tout à fait raison de souligner qu'il va
continuer car l'Europe s'inscrit dans la
durée de ce conflit parce que si ce
conflit effectivement si les FC par
exemple n'arrive pas rapidement on parle
du mois de septembre octobre et bien
c'est une un conflit qui va durer très
longtemps et l'essentiel c'est de
pouvoir soutenir notamment sur le plan
militaire mais également sur le plan
économique et financier il faut savoir
qu'aujourd'hui l'Europe parmi d'autres
nations soutient à bout de bras les
finances publiques ukrainiennes c'est ça
aujourd'hui il faut non seulement
soutenir en terme d'armement en termes
économique mais il faut également
soutenir ce plan financier pour payer
les militaires payer les infirmiers les
médecins tous ces gens qui contribuent à
ce que l'Ukraine puisse continuer à
vivre est-ce que ça veut dire que la
question de la livraison d'avions va se
reposer du côté de l'Europe
elle se pose plus la décision a été
prise et puis l'autre commençait à être
formé donc la décision de fournir des
F-7 ne se pose plus simplement le
problème c'est que ça sera pas pour
cette offensive là oui ça arrivera
probablement au début de l'automne et
donc au moment où normalement
l'offensive ne pourra plus progresser
donc voilà mais ça ça veut dire un
engagement sur le long terme on s'engage
pas pour fournir alors on s'engage pour
fournir de munitions aujourd'hui et des
F-16 demain ça veut dire que dans sur le
long terme on s'organise pour soutenir
l'Ukraine c'est vrai que des pilotes
sont en cours de formation on le sait
même au Royaume-Uni seul problème c'est
que la Maison Blanche aux États-Unis est
un peu plus réservée on sait que les
États-Unis sont en dans un contexte
électoral l'élection présidentielle de
2024 et que donc il y a un vrai débat le
fait de former des pilotes ça veut dire
effectivement que la décision est prise
mais on pour l'instant les États-Unis
eux-mêmes ne livreraient pas de F16 on
va demander aux États européens à le
faire donc c'est très important et ce ne
sera pas quelques avions de chasse qui
feront la différence il faut vraiment
mettre le paquet en d'autres termes si
on veut que cette guerre se termine très
rapidement c'est à dire dès l'année
prochaine et bien il faut vraiment
mettre le paquet en termes de défense
aérienne la maîtrise du ciel est quelque
chose d'essentiel sans quoi c'est une
guerre qui va encore durer longtemps
parce que je vous rappellerai que ne
parle plus de la Crimée est-ce que la
Crimée doit revenir à l'Ukraine tout le
monde dit oui sauf qu'aujourd'hui il y a
quand même des gens qui posent des
questions il y a les militaires il y a
les diplomates et beaucoup parlent
encore de négociations par exemple la
délégation africaine qui est allée donc
à Kiev puis à Moscou à Saint-Pétersbourg
a proposé un plan de médiation la Chine
également mais ça a échoué et donc dans
l'esprit de certaines chancellerie
occidentales on parle toujours de tenter
de régler cette guerre par une
négociation juste un point sur les F16
remarquable manœuvre commerciale
américaine les Américains acceptent que
les Européens livres des F-16 et ne vous
inquiétez pas en vous livrera des avions
dernière génération à condition que vous
les achetiez donc c'est un coin quand
même sur la défense européenne et sur
les les moyens communs de défense
européenne les Américains ont donné leur
accord pour les F16 il y a plus de doute
là-dessus simplement sont pas les F-16
américains son lf16 européen et
naturellement les pays européens devront
s'équiper de nouveaux avions et les
Américains seront prêts pour livrer ces
nouveaux avions donc le diable est dans
les détails comme d'habitude il faut
regarder ça de près les Américains font
toujours du business de toute façon quoi
qu'il arrive donc du coup juste un
dernier mot pour conclure la
contre-offensive général trinquant c'est
il faut être patient le temps médiatique
n'est pas le temps militaire exactement
soyons patients on suivra évidemment
tout ça on aura l'occasion d'en parler
avec vous merci Monsieur si vous voulez
bien rester avec nous on va regarder ce
qu'elle a une de nos quotidiens
régionaux ce matin
[Musique]
et Mathias ce mardi on parle météo et
les orages font toujours parler de hein
il faut dire qu'entre dimanche et lundi
ce sont plusieurs dizaines de
départements qui ont connu une alerte
orage donc sur tout le territoire
sud-ouest fait un constat tout se
dérègle avec une saison des orages qui
démarre plutôt et des orages plus
violents le Berry Républicain fait état
d'importants dégâts matériels dans le
département du Cher avec des toits
envolés et des épisodes de grêle enfin
l'édition de Dieppe de Paris Normandie
mais assez une le nettoyage des rues là
aussi après les importances orages du
week-end on en parlait du Salon du
Bourget il est aussi représenté dans nos
régions c'est la République des Pyrénées
qui met à l'honneur ce mardi des
entreprises de la région de Bigorre qui
sont représentés au Salon International
de l'Aéronautique derrière spécialisé
dans la conception d'avion léger et le
groupe seigneurie au tracteur bigourdan
de l'aéronautique ils sont confrontés
comme toute la filière au défi majeur de
l'avenir à savoir la décarbonation du
secteur de l'aviation mais aussi un
manque de manœuvres Oriane un autre
secteur qui manque de main d'oeuvre
c'est le service alors à tel point que
le journal La Provence dédié sa Une au
sujet avec un titre sans équivoque
recherche serveur désespérément hôtelier
restaurateur s'arrachent les cheveux
dans toute la région provençale
peut-côte d'Azur près de 18000 postes de
saisonniers sont à pourvoir alors malgré
un effort sur les salaires les candidats
ne courent pas les rues les étudiants
notamment sont deux sont de plus en plus
réfractaires à prendre ce type de job
d'été car vient rapidement la question
du logement ce qui est un autre
casse-tête les jeunes pourraient aussi
prochainement conduire dès 17 ans oui
c'est une mesure qui devrait être
annoncée cette semaine par la première
ministre le permis à 17 ans mais
pourquoi faire et bien notamment pour
permettre aux jeunes des zones rurales
d'aller vers plus d'autonomie lorsque
l'offre de transport en commun n'est pas
suffisante voir inexistante ou encore
les aider à en matière d'insertion
professionnelle pour ceux ayant besoin
de se déplacer pour rejoindre leur lieu
de travail par le foot pour terminer
pour finir avis aux amoureux
Bourguignons du Dijon nouveau le Côte
d'Or alors le club devrait prochainement
passer sous pavillon américain encore
Olivier Delcourt dirigeant d'entreprises
locales et propriétaire du DFCO depuis
11 ans va passer la main des
investisseurs venus des États-Unis après
Lyon Marseille Oriane Le Havre Toulouse
Bordeaux ou encore le Red Star voici un
peu le respect encore un autre club
voilà qui est habitué du monde pro qui
pourrait passer entre les mains du pays
du soccer merci Mathias supporters
fervent supporter du Red Star merci
beaucoup pour cette revue de presse
merci Patrick Martin Genier d'avoir été
avec nous on revoit votre livre l'Europe
a-t-elle un avenir cette édition
Studyrama merci d'avoir été avec nous
merci généraltr et à bientôt j'espère
dans cette émission merci à tous de nous
avoir suivis pour voir ou revoir cette
émission c'est sur notre plateforme
public sénat.fr à 18h vous avez
rendez-vous avec Thomas eu pour sciences
publiques et nous on se retrouve demain
très bonne journée
[Musique]